[Music]
build-a-bear launches an adults-only
production line huh on a new 18 and up
section of their website no
way
entitled build-a-bear after dark what is
it because i saw this one play uh not
playboy it was a it was an amateur made
porn
um i was like really horny i was i was
really shocked like we need to know that
before he looks
okay out one of those big bears right
like the costco ones a little bit
smaller maybe like the carnival maybe
this big like this the simp gift one
that's what happens to the bear she put
a [ __ ] strap on on the bear and she
[ __ ] it
it was one of the hottest things i've
ever seen i didn't realize
i was into animal porn oh
maybe that's the gateway for me to start
wanting to [ __ ] a bear my teddy bear is
not animal porn but sure did she have
beastiality she reversed cowgirl did or
like
she straddled it wow on its back yeah
she put a dildo on the bear straddled it
and wrote it and i was like this is
[ __ ] hot did the bear come did you
see the bear's face we're all asking
that
you're all wondering dude the bear's
face is important to the story for me i
wanna that reminds me of a [ __ ]
totally unrelated situation where uh
i pranked my teacher junior year of high
school he had a big ass bear that was
hanging at the corner of his class and i
got some clay from a different class and
i made a fake like big-ass dick
and i and i mounted it to the bear to
see how long it take him to find out
i made like a it was nice it's like a
little like very artistic strong stick
balls there's some calm on it wow and
then um so he he's the kind of guy that
i thought he would just laugh but
instead he like uh was really pissed and
he was like i need you to like come to
my office he cried and then so i'm
sitting in there i think he's i'm like
oh dude he actually got mad what the
[ __ ]
and he goes just tell me what the white
stuff was
wait he knows what his stuff was oh he
he wants to make sure no he really
wanted to genuinely know how i made gum
on the dick but i took my oreos and i
took the white stuff and i made [ __ ] on
the dick and he goes
just just tell me that how did you do it
just tell me how you did your [ __ ]
how did you make white stuff then he
gave you a scholarship to art school
[Laughter]
he's like ryan i knew he had potential
the fbi gave you a job at [ __ ]
replication
no replicate replicate.com i thought he
was turning the tables around
where now he's going to corner you
molest you oh whoa that took a big turn
as usual thanks bart
someone's switching me bro no
i thought it was one of those situations
right here tell me how you made the
white stuff what are you talking about
tell me how you made the [ __ ] white
show me how you doing
how you made pull your [ __ ] pants
down and show me and i was like oh
this is a bart lived experience i mean i
guess that would be poetic justice for
what i did no but he was laughing his
ass he just he was trying to make me
scared thinking i got in trouble but he
really just genuinely wanted he was
puzzled i could see bart interjecting
with like you know sometimes like the
teacher turns the tables on you and
we're all like no
[Laughter]
you know when they finally actually
happened to me so i think my junior
senior year we went me and my boys went
camping and we took a picture we just
thought it would be funny all of our uh
my butt cheeks from the back we all
pulled our pants down at her butt cheeks
hanging out and then classic my english
teacher uh she's like already looking at
her over there and then i was like oh uh
we went camping last weekend they're
gonna see some pictures she's like sure
so i showed it to her and there's like
six dudes with their ass cheeks out
and then uh she filed the sexual
harassment theme against me because you
showed it to her yeah and then i and
then i have to explain to my mom like
what sexual harassment even means she
had to pick me up from school
and there's yeah it was weird
you have gotten in trouble in every
possible way you don't know how to make
a joke you have so many stories
that are all in every lane of crime
every for every every category of
trouble you can get it i understand why
your mom's a gangster now yeah she had
to deal with so much [ __ ] dude i
understand
why would that beat your ethan allen
dude
i get why you shiver around ethan
allen's now
so yeah this build-a-bear thing is sort
of similar to one of those things where
it's sort of a baiting switch where it's
not nearly as dirty as it sounds
but uh here's a good look at what i'm
talking about oh it's for valentine's
day
valentine's day oh man build a beer
after dark it's valentine's day it's one
of the gifts you [ __ ] took it a
different route but so did they got me
too like joe shared a personal story
about his porn those are kind of cute
some of those are pretty cute is it
holding wine though come on that's a
little bit yeah you're not gonna find
one hey it's after dark dude they said
it it's one o'clock somewhere it's so
good
bring on the bubbly that's a bunny
that's pretty good right have you guys
been to build-a-bear yeah you got to be
18 and plus to really get that or they
just [ __ ] with you you got to be an
18 up to to enter the site it's like a
nice it's a it's a really cool little
it's like a porn site because nobody
[ __ ] says no they're trying to play
on this whole experience i mean it's
just a marketing guy's brainchild of
like how to get people talking about
something
before you watch the video on the porn
site is there a an ad for a bear getting
[ __ ]
wanna play a game is there a cartoon
bear a cartoon laura croft bear
getting [ __ ] by a demon
you got bear bart simpson and [ __ ]
[ __ ] lisa simpson or marge dude i
know
bear marsh's hair is going up homer
simpson's ass
[ __ ] bear mill house out there eating
out lisa and [ __ ] i [ __ ] hate those
ads man
bear
out of the whole [ __ ] man what's going
on
i hope
i'd rather see an ad for this yeah all
right that i clicked and saved all that
stuff
well it is hard to confuse right click
and left click save save as save as yeah
do you guys have valentine's day plants
hidden folder it's all you know
valentine's day the only plan that me
and uh nina talked about was not
spending as much money as because you
know every [ __ ] restaurant gets this
crazy new marketing promo i do it's like
valentine's dinner that's the only thing
on the menu so they up charge everything
you have to have like five courses
that's like a fixed dinner yeah yeah for
like 250 to eat for some [ __ ] yeah
so then we're always just kind of like
you know what we're just gonna we're
just gonna cook it at home specifically
you know is it gonna be more expensive
on valentine's do you think oh my god it
always is it's always one of those host
mates
yeah they don't do a valentine's day
popeye says no valentine's specials
whatsoever bart are you doing something
for jio for valentine's day you [ __ ] yep
what do you have what are you doing
[Laughter]
you can't do last minute [ __ ] it's all
booked up i know you're gonna get a
[ __ ] build-a-bear hey there you go
you're welcome dude build a bear after
dark i booked that [ __ ] the day after
christmas day oh you're smart because
otherwise i'd be [ __ ] you're too
intelligent right what do you guys got
planned so i'm taking her to our new
favorite restaurant which is i'll tell
you off camera okay and the burger the
king
burger the king my burger king actually
pal
what kind of food is it
what kind of food is it
italiano there's some real good italian
places all over vegas there's a lot
there's a lot yeah and so i booked it
way in advance and she loves this place
he'll be sick and then um
uh
afterward i'm gonna take her like this
little speakeasy place because she likes
that kind of [ __ ] like yeah she likes a
couple drinks yeah she looks like the
gastropub thing yeah i'm gonna do that
i'm gonna [ __ ] the [ __ ] out when we get
home
come on man
that's good i got a hotel suite we're
gonna do it early and spend the [ __ ]
several days just
having a good time
[Laughter]
i wanted to get a place where there's a
big [ __ ] tub
so we could soak in a tub and talk about
feelings and [ __ ] you know what i mean
and then
big ass room so there's multiple places
you could ground and pound that
ground
you know what i mean i'm talking about
it i wanted a refrigerator so we could
get food and not leave the room can i
ask if we can cut this if you don't like
it
have you have you said the l word yet to
her a thousand percent especially during
when i'm high having sex hell yeah bro
but in real life i'm a man bro come on
yeah when i'm sober i ain't gonna say
[ __ ] like that's that [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
take that [ __ ] to yourself [ __ ]
i agree
i agree but when she's riding on my dick
cool he's so excited he's so [ __ ]
cool should i put it in your lip right
on my [ __ ] dip yup
and she's like oh daddy's getting dead
and i'm like i love you girl
daddy daddy daddy he's getting cooler
dude he's fearing loathing right now i'm
going to las vegas for that reason but
you know what uh she's such a discount
[ __ ] you know what's [ __ ] cool right
i was like check this out this guy's so
cool we can go to
we can go to valentine's day
for this price and get this place
or would you like to go to this place
get a way [ __ ] bigger room with a
bathtub and a [ __ ] dope view and all
this [ __ ] for like a third of the price
and she goes you know my answer a third
of the price well we might not be able
to do it on valentine's day but you down
to do it during the weekday and instead
of one day of celebration we'll
celebrate for four
see go back to circus circus buffet i
see hell yeah bro
that's how i roll that's all i got back
to jk i was quitting i said [ __ ] all you
guys on my podcast and i was like [ __ ]
these guys i don't [ __ ] care about jk
anymore and then you guys came to l.a
took me to [ __ ] circuit circus buffet
and i was like all right they got some
it's magic man man people don't know how
to seduce
i [ __ ] seduced his mouth and it's
harder to introduce men huh man to man
seduction man to men is hard because you
can't use lady parts
men seduction is easy a girl puts on a
[ __ ] mini skirt and it's done dude
nikki's just doing her makeup in front
of the mirror this morning and she's
wearing like i'm not she wearing pajama
pants and i'm like god damn that ass is
[ __ ] nice you're seduced
doesn't take much how do you do how do
you do it after so many years of
marriage how do you keep valentine's day
fresh well he's only been with
2.1 chicks
she actually she bumped into him at the
grocery store oh my god i'm sorry and
then like she he felt the back of her
hand on his dick real quick that's the
point when he just looked like yep yep
two point one when did you get with your
your your uh wife now like from um what
grade i was a
senior that's a high school sweetheart
from senior
yeah and then did you do you guys
celebrate valentine's day every year
yeah we do like our own variation of it
we don't do anything too crazy what do
you do like eat a moon cake
we give we we do this thing where we get
red packets and we put money in it and
we send it to everyone that we know
that's how we celebrate our valentine's
day
we're gonna go to san diego we're gonna
go to a concert
and then and then we're gonna uh hang
out for a couple days and then come back
and then you know that's it that's what
we're gonna do we keep it real simple
that's cute yeah do you beat the cheeks
for valentine's day she beats my cheeks
wow
she got your butt cheeks going like this
to each of their own you know what i
mean i'm glad i'm in a room full of guys
that could accept me for who i am i
appreciate you guys
no you accept a lot of things we that's
what you're saying oh yeah i accept
everything and it's really cool i'm i'm
i'm thankful for you guys thank you guys
good man turn the [ __ ] camera off man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you